[Musique]
on
d'abord c'est faux madame le ministre
réacteurs de taishan
mais un merci monsieur le rapporte que
monsieur la rapporteure je ne résiste
pas à lire un tweet que vous avez dit ce
matin lorsque vous dites monsieur la
rapporteure c'est une provocation et je
ne veux pas la laisser passer
demande de manière très claire elle être
appelée madame la ministre si monsieur
le député ne respecte pas cela eh bien
il sera appelé monsieur le rapporteur et
j'en prends la plaine responsable dames
la ministre non je crois que là là vous
ne pouvez pas tordre les usages de la
langue je remixe ici mais je m'appelle
madame le ministre c'est un usage validé
par l'académie française en revanche
monsieur la rapporteure je suis allée
part je regrette
[Musique]
et